voilà
free
[Musique]
m
d
[Musique]
transfigure oh là là pour le vaccin
je suis nicole et chardy je suis
éducatrice de jeunes enfants à la
protection maternelle infantile la pmi
qui est un des services du conseil
départemental à la pmi ont ce que peu de
l'enfant de sa conception jusqu'à 6 ans
en ce qui concerne le gap
nous recevons des enfants qui sont
accompagnés de l'un des parents entre
trois mois à peu près jusqu'à l'entrée à
l'école maternelle
[Musique]
oh
alors le gap groupe d'accueil parents
enfants est une expérience enrichissante
autant pour les parents que pour les
enfants
ça permet les échanges entre les parents
et les professionnels mais aussi entre
les parents eux mêmes
nous sommes là pour accompagner les
parents durant cette activité les
enfants rencontrent d'autres enfants
mais aussi aux parents de créer une
meilleure relation avec leurs enfants et
des liens beaucoup plus fort tout en
jouant
[Musique]
allez
ça permet aussi aux enfants de
développer leur capacité en priorité la
motricité le langage l'intelligence
les tout bébé reste sur le tapis pour
jouer il évolue selon leurs capacités
ensuite dans le groupe où les enfants
marchent déjà il ya des activités plus
diversifiés comme aujourd'hui nous avons
fait de la peinture
tu peux remettre sur moi c'est mieux
d'être là sur ta feuille c'est pas cool
et jolie
[Musique]
alors pour chaque groupe d'enfants
nous adaptons les jouer en fonction de
leur âge donc les bébés ils ont des
petits auch et ils ont déjoué à bascule
déjoué facilement manipulable tandis que
les plus grands ils peuvent avoir des
puzzles des lego des petites voitures
voilà si en fonction de l'âge de
l'enfant
[Musique]
oh
qui
pour les enfants c'est un lieu où se
familiarisent avec d'autres enfants
d'autres adultes et c'est un début de
socialisation
les parents se sentent plus en confiance
dans l'éducation de leurs enfants
puisqu'ils bénéficient de l'expérience
des autres parents mais aussi de l'aide
des professionnels qui sont là pour les
guider dans leur rôle parental pour
s'inscrire à ce genre d'activités il
suffit d'appeler à la paix mis de votre
secteur
les familles sont ces petits d'être
invité à cette activité
nous informons dès la naissance de
l'enfant à la maternité par une
opératrice qui passent dans les
maternités les auxiliaires de culture et
qui vont à domicile et aussi en
consultation de nourrissons
certaines formations et donner à toutes
les familles et les familles intéressées
viennent à ces groupes
cannes est que nos îles et psycho tour
est trouble où les six points qui va
tomber dans le pays où tout mais dalo